I hope you've at least written this lie
down this is the easy life to write but
i want you to see you remember we pulled
this trick before and you have that one
on a on the top right when you bring it
on the denominator and then stick it
underneath the square root sign it
becomes an a squared and so that's why
everything is nice and neat but then
over here it's look like the same is it
won't you notice that here you want an a
squared to cancel out at the bottom but
you don't have an x squared up there and
is the square root or the denominator to
turn your a in turn a square you could
just leave it as it is and you'll have a
fraction something else we're over here
mathematicians kind of want it to be
nicer and the time i'm in a more
symmetrical so here's what's today of
course it is so once you have your sides
right here's what they do to make it a
little nicer idea what I really want is
I want i squared up in this denominator
okay what would i have to multiply this
whole rain inside by to get a one on a
squared up there it's a one and A right
if i multiply this by one an a this will
become one on a squared but of course
you can't just go around multiply things
because they're nicer need are this is
an equation so i need to keep everything
balanced okay so i multiply the right
head side by one today I better multiply
the left-hand side by lata may as well
you see what I've done there okay so
noticing that this is just the constant
I can take you in and out of this to
reduce favorite as I please I'm just
going to stick him inside because this
guy it's not quite as neat as what I had
before but what it gives me on the right
hand side is that it's right what
happens with that a squid migrates down
for the numerator to the denominator
what do I get on a very good this is
multiplying everything throughout the
dominance that's a square and this guy
just cancels out so you get something
quite similar to what I had over there
and just like I'm not a derivative
statement I can now write an integral
statement that goes with it okay so if i
take this right-hand side
and I integrate with respect to X ok I'm
going to get this sky well be careful
it's got this one on a at the front
which cited verse did not have ok so i'm
going to write it like so ok now i was
fiddling around my cables before number
1 i'll put a color run it number one and
two these are your reference sheet let
me show you saturday you yeah we'll do
it we'll do a numerical example in a
second ok so here's page three of the
reference sheet which you've seen and
used before it's basically because this
is the extension one page and so that's
why you expect to find i inverse trig
there because there's no industrial tuna
ok so you come over here this has
further integrals there are the two
results that we just proved they're nice
and neat except there is a conspicuous
absence from our list right there's side
inverse and there's tan inverse and
where's cause of us okay so cuz if this
is not there explicitly it actually is
there right let me try and show you
where it is simple example you don't
need to write this path but as local
college if i asked to say what's the
integral of 2x DX tell me what that I
bet you're a tease I've integrative
we're going to be really good at
switching back and forth because you're
going to have to do both a different
times the same paper okay so this guy is
x squared plus C yes what is this a
general what is this a specific case on
what's the general rule that goes with
this if I have some kind of polynomial
Paolo you like say X to power back yeah
and I'm integrating that with respect to
X what you did was you increase the
power it went from one to two yeah so
this is going to become X to the n plus
1 and then I had to divide by whatever
that you power was which is exactly what
you did to cancel out that true plus my
closet ok that leases now that's fine
you can do everything like this in this
form would it be just if I will say oh
it's a whole new rule to say well if I
put a minus sign there this is a whole
new thing would that be justifiable or
needed what are really right it's like
this is so similar this is so similar to
this it really there's no point and
that's kind of why I let's let's assume
back out and we go to 2 unit where is he
this here is kind of they've got to step
further so this is kind of a good chain
rule they've got a whole linear function
in there but that's just another version
of this ok so I've got one extra step ok
and it's not like oh yeah I have this
integral and then I also have the one
where there's a negative sign out the
front now you get a negative sign here
because it's just the constant agreed ok
now pause this for a second nope when we
go down this statement here is David
here I asked you to dodge the cause of
most wanted to move on to tell you this
okay what would happen if we rewrote and
you don't need to do any computation ok
just think with me and use the
comparison of your pocket if I would you
like the same statement for cos inverse
how would it look the derivative of cos
inverse of sine X on a what would it be
this could be exactly the same except
with a negative sign on the front right
do you agree with that huh so once
you've got here and we showed this
geometrical you've improved it properly
is it because these things their
derivatives are only off by a constant
okay therefore won't you come over to
actually just like here when you come to
make this statement instead of sine
inverse here if I had a minus here right
this could be cos inverse right this
could be causing us the minus could be
there or the minus could be here could
just multiply both sides by negative 1
okay so i could say the integral are one
on the square root of a squared minus x
squared with respect to x maybe i didn't
come from cider inverse then what i came
from was negative cos inverse right
posture cousin just think about what
these look like okay um this might be
worth just roughly sketching beside all
this and you have the picture together
it doesn't need a big one what does sine
inverse of like and what would negative
is the right place to put it what would
negative cos inverse look like okay
we're really good at sine inverse by now
so we're getting this kind of shape
right now we know what regular clothes
in post looks like it would be up here
on right so when you slap that minus
sign on the front it reflects that's why
I we drew this bottom part of it right
and what's it going to look like instead
of this that's the regular one you're
going to get this guy's which at every
point in which it exists has the same
gradient as this does that make sense so
here's your gradient function over here
and its head okay when you integrate
where will you end up and the answer is
you could end up here that's like an
obvious place to go but you wanted to
you could just state it like that as
well free question there is still the
difference between these through this
they're not the same function what's the
difference the answer is it's a constant
right your shifted up and down how much
yeah and we should have known that
because one of the firsts earlier agent
needs I shown you was this guy right
it's equal to play on too so all I have
to do to turn sign of us a new cousin
bonus is say I'll put the sign up okay
stop a minus sign on the front like this
and then if you shift it upwards play on
two units then you come up to be exactly
the same assign inverse so that's why
the one courtesy sine inverse intervals
there 10 inverse integrals their clothes
in this it's not there because you get
it from the sign in verse 1 it is so
similar they were only off by a negative
sign and the constant which is already
there that's why it's not an extra thing
that's on me okay so don't feel like our
they're missing something no these are
so connected you don't need to stay both
of them okay